hey schön dass ihr dabei seid bei zdf
heute live mehr als 100.000 soldaten
sollen es sein die russland an der
grenze zur ukraine zusammen gezogen hat
es ist schwer das nicht als drohung zu
verstehen sagt die aussenministerin
annalena baerbock heute bei ihrem
antrittsbesuch in moskau und der beginnt
dann gleich damit wirklich mit einer
großen diplomatischen herausforderungen
und großen fragen wie soll man russland
wieder an den verhandlungstisch bekommen
wie lässt sich dieser jahrelange
konflikt mit der ukraine lösen und das
ist auch eine frage die uns hier alle in
europa irgendwie betrifft und da stellt
sich eben und unserer sendung heute auch
die frage wie gefährlich kann dieser
ukraine konflikt noch werden und wir
möchten dazu sprechen jetzt ganz am
anfang heute erst mal dazu zu den
ergebnissen der pressekonferenz die die
außenministerin heute zusammen mit dem
russischen aussenminister gegeben hat
und da möchte ich meinen kollegen den
korrespondenten christiansen in moskau
dazu betten gegen abend christian
hallo guten abend alisa es war das erste
zusammentreffen jetzt in der form also
von außenministerin annalena baerbock
sie ist neu im amt noch relativ neu und
eben darauf wie war denn dieser auftakt
zwischen diesen beiden rennen
also wenn man das ergebnis des treffens
bewerten will dann kommt natürlich
darauf an was man davon erwartet hat
wenn man jetzt erwartet hat das ist eine
tief greifende antwort auf diese krise
in der ukraine gibt der wurde natürlich
enttäuscht aber es gab andere
bemerkenswerte dinge heute das war ja
ein antrittsbesuch
annalena baerbock erster besuch hier in
moskau bei einem sehr erfahrenen
politiker bei sergej lavrov der seit
2004 russische außenminister ist und da
haben alle gespannt hier drauf gewartet
und darauf geschaut wie die beiden sich
begegnen denn es gab ja schon den einen
oder anderen politiker der hier auch vor
laufenden kameras so ziemlich gegen die
wand gelaufen ist dafür ist sergei
lavrov berüchtigt das ist nicht passiert
die beiden hatten angekündigt und
versprochen sich zuzuhören sich die
jeweiligen argumente anzuhören und das
haben sie auch getan und ich glaube die
atmosphäre war schon kühl aber jetzt
auch nicht komplett unfreundlich und ich
glaube das ist eine basis zumindest was
nur das angeht wo man mit weiteren
gesprächen vielleicht auch darauf
aufbauen kann und danach wurde auch
bekannt dass die gespräche weitergehen
also das war jetzt im prinzip so der
auftrag für einen neuen
verhandlungsmarathon wenn man so will
und neue diplomatische gespräche morgen
soll ja der us aussenminister blinken in
kiew mit präsident lenski
zusammentreffen dann danach weiter nach
berlin reisen dort trifft er dann
außenministerin baerbock und am freitag
sollen sich us-außenminister blinken und
der russische außenminister lawrow auf
dann in genf treffen also es wird weiter
miteinander geredet und das ist
vielleicht auch erst mal ein gutes
zeichen dass man miteinander redet
versucht die argumente zu hören eine
lösung zu finden auch wenn die im moment
vielleicht noch nicht so wirklich in
sicht ist das sonst gleich noch mal kurz
im detail sprechen aber wir haben erst
mal einen beitrag von axel sturm der
noch mal den heutigen tag und alles alle
all das was da gesagt wurde
zusammenfasst
gut eineinhalb stunden verspätet öffnen
sich die türen im gästehaus des
außenministeriums pressekonferenz die
neue deutsche außenministerin hat für
das gespräch mit ihrem russischen
kollegen sergej lavrov eine wie sie sagt
dicke themen mappe mitgebracht vieles
das verbinde aber auch eine klare
haltung zum russischen truppenaufmarsch
an der grenze zur ukraine
in den letzten wochen haben sich mehr
als hundert tausend russische soldaten
mit panzern und geschützen der nähe der
ukraine versammelt ohne
nachvollziehbaren grund und es ist
schwer das nicht als drohung zu
verstehen
wir haben erklärt dass es keine
eskalation gibt es von der westliche
politiker derzeit sprechen gemeint ist
die präsenz unserer eigenen truppen auf
dem eigenen territorium und die
durchführung notwendiger
gefechtsausbildung
ripley
gehört durfte die deutsche
spitzendiplomat in cham geschichts und
selbstbewusst und dialogbereit nach
moskau das war auch ihre zentrale
nachricht über die ukraine krise müsse
wieder verhandelt werden in etablierten
kreis jetzt ist es aus unserer sicht
wichtig den normandie prozess wieder mit
leben zu füllen um endlich bei der
implementierung der minsker vereinbarung
voranzukommen kiew moskau berlin und
paris an einem tisch begeisterungsstürme
gab es für diese idee nicht heute in
moskau aber auch keine deutliche absage
es ist noch nicht so viel konkretes
dabei herausgekommen das haben mir
gehört aber russland hat auf der einen
seite immer wieder betont sie wollen
sicherheitsgarantien und deutschland
annalena baerbock hat betonte sie möchte
dass russland eben die gemeinsamen
regeln in europa ein held wie kann das
zusammengehen wo siehst du da jetzt
möglichkeiten wie das weitergehen könnte
ja ich denke das wurde heute auch noch
mal deutlich dass da beide seiten ganz
klar auf ihren prinzipien beharren man
kann das ja sogar einen größeren kontext
noch sehen wenn man das deutsch
russische verhältnis sieht das ist sehr
schlecht und wird seit jahren auch immer
schlechter und die themenliste diaz lang
die ist da gibt es zum beispiel der fall
wenn die das im verhältnis sehr belastet
hat das hat annalena baerbock heute auch
angesprochen das heißt die
menschenrechtssituation in russland
wo die lage immer schwieriger wird für
die opposition höhe für die opposition
hier und für menschenrechtler das sind
viele punkte und wenn man jetzt die
aktuelle krise noch dazu nimmt versucht
natürlich jede seite da keinen
millimeter abstriche zu machen aber ich
glaube beide seiten wissen dass man
irgendwie ins gespräch kommen muss und
das ist eine lösung gefunden werden muss
und wenn wir über die ukraine sprechen
hatte annalena baerbock angekündigt
schon im vorfeld dass sie wieder dafür
werben will dass russland ins sogenannte
normandie format kommt also wo man auch
über den frieden in der ost ukraine
gemeinsam berät also die ukraine
russland unter der vermittlung von
deutschland und frankreich und da gab es
heute jetzt schon mal vorsichtige
signale dass es zumindest da irgendwann
zu einem treffen wieder kommen könnte
und das wäre natürlich auch wieder ein
punkt wo man wieder miteinander ins
gespräch kommen
kurz noch zum ende die frage es wurde im
vorfeld jetzt auch immer wieder
debattiert muss deutschland muss europa
schon klar machen was vielleicht auch
auf dem spiel steht was für sanktionen
im falle von deutschland wurde jetzt
auch immer wieder diskutiert geht es da
auch vielleicht um die gaspipeline die
umstrittene nord stream 2 steht hier
also vielleicht auch zur debatte war das
thema heute wurde das angesprochen
also ist sergei lavrov hat es in der
pressekonferenz einmal deutlich gemacht
wie wichtig das projekt für russland ist
innerhalb der bundesregierung gab es da
ja zumindest in der letzten zeit nicht
wirklich eine einigkeit wie man mit dem
projekt umgeht die grünen natürlich
gegner dieses projekts und kanzler
scholz hat sich immer wieder dazu
geäußert das als rein
privatwirtschaftliches
projekt bezeichnete wofür wofür
natürlich auch immer viel kritik
bekommen hat also da sucht die
bundesregierung nach einer gemeinsamen
linie aber ich denke man weiß schon
welche faust fand man sozusagen in der
hand hätte wenn es zu einer eskalation
käme und das wäre sicherlich auch der
punkt also würde der konflikt mit der
ukraine eskalieren also würden russische
truppen auf ukrainisches gebiet kommen
dann hätte das natürlich konsequenzen
für die gaspipeline und daneben sind ja
auch noch andere sanktionen sun drohung
im raum aber ich hatte das gefühl dass
die direkte androhung für diese
konsequenzen dass das heute bei dem
gespräch nicht so eine große rolle
gespielt hat beide seiten haben ihre
ihre roten linien noch einmal klar
gemacht und ihre position aber es war
nicht der tag
sich noch mal gegenseitig zu attackieren
danke für die einordnung christian
seinem nach moskau
und wir haben jetzt in der sendung im
verlauf natürlich noch viel zeit auch
gerade für eure fragen bringt sie gerne
ein ihr könnt uns jederzeit schreiben
viele von euch wissen das schon an die
e-mailadresse die wir euch aber gerne
nochmal einblenden oder auch einfach
direkt im stream könnt ihr kommentieren
bei youtube facebook wo ihr unterwegs
sein wir wollen jetzt zunächst mal kurz
auch noch darüber sprechen wie sich das
eigentlich anfühlen muss diese bedrohung
die da jetzt gerade stattfindet an der
grenze eben zur ukraine wie geht's also
den menschen in der ukraine und wie es
auch die stimmung in russland und da wir
uns eingeladen den schriftsteller
wladimir kaminer er selbst wurde in
moskau geboren und die großeltern
wiederum die kommen aus der ukraine er
kennt also beide seiten schönen guten
abend herr kaminer
guten morgen herr kaminer sie verfolgen
natürlich auch intensiv was da gerade
vor sich geht wie ist denn jetzt auch
geraden am heutigen tag nach also dem
treffen zwischen deutschland und
russland wie ist denn die stimmung bei
den russinnen und russen bei diesem
ganzen thema jetzt gerade
in russland kommt
diese bedrohung eines krieges nicht gut
an ich denke bei der bevölkerung wird
eine eine solche aggression keine breite
zustimmung finden die ukraine erleben
gerade einen großen patrioten einen ein
ausbruch des vertrages muss und
alle wollen ihre heimat verteidigen aber
ich glaube es wird zu klein und krieg
kommen die sonst zwischen einem guten
und einem angedrohten krieg ist ein
großer unterschied ein geführter krieg
ist eine sichere sache er kann sehr
schnell
ebenso eine niederlage werden und dann
einen verlorenen einen verlorenen krieg
ganze die russische führung nicht
leisten dass der würde dann das ende
dieser präsident chance bedeuten
eine angedrohte krieg dafür aber
erstaunlicherweise
für alle seiten vorteile
[Musik]
für selbst zu europa der nato nato war
er schon
fast ein totgesagte verein plötzlich
erlebt die nato eine solche einigkeit
europäische lernen konnten eine sehr
klare und unmissverständliche antwort
auf diese russische aggression
geben ich glaube sie können diese
problematik meiner besten männer als
korrupt wie sie sagen für alle seiten
hätte das vorteile aber für die ukraine
die sich der in dieser einschüchterung
da irrt regelmäßig aussetzen muss das
wahrscheinlich nicht oder auf
dauer ist das natürlich für eine junge
demokratie sehr anstrengend ständig
unter der gefahr einer aggression zu
leben habe gleichzeitig erlebt ukraine
ein einer und eine unglaublich 1 1
1 feuerwerk an des politischen handelns
also
sehr viele parteien stehen jetzt ein
wettbewerb zueinander in der ukraine und
wollen zeigen dass sie die besseren
schutz des griechischen volkes sind
ja auf dauer ist das ist das natürlich
schlecht da kann man da kann man
natürlich nicht so
eine langfristige politik darauf bauen
außerdem kann die ukraine möchte als
europäisches land anerkannt werden sie
will ein teil europa werden und ist
dafür bereit
auch für europa
ihre stirn dem russischen aggressiver zu
bieten bloß nur diese bereitschaft ist
gerade eine schlechte
einer einer
eine schlechte ware auf dem europäischen
markt da sind niemand möchte in europa
sich mit russland anlegen und
deutschland am wenigsten ich möchte
heute steht er entschuldigung nicht
einmal die waffen an die ukraine und
verkaufen sie warfen sie dann auf der
russischen kann im fall der fälle das
sagen die irgendwann wird es doch
vorgemacht ich würde gerne kurz die
stimmung hier auch im stream aufgreifen
es gibt schon ein paar kommentare zum
beispiel andreas krieger bei youtube
schreibt bitte kein krieg gespräche mit
russland führen und auch michael schmidt
bei facebook schreibt ich denke man
sollte mit russland im gespräch bleiben
damit man mal weiß was sie wollen bitte
diplomatisch bleiben und die ukraine
schützen was sagen sie denn her kamin an
sie haben ja nach wie vor auch noch
natürlich viele freunde familie auch in
russland
ist denn die bemühungen jetzt von
deutscher seite von europäischer seite
von den anderen staaten in europa auf
russland zu zugehen aber eben gerade
auch von deutscher seite ist das genug
gewesen in den letzten jahren ist man da
genug im gespräch geblieben
also für russische führung ist diese
angebote krieg auch eine gelegenheit die
gescheiterten politik die gescheiterte
wirtschaftliche politik innerhalb des
landes durch eine erfolgreiche
außenpolitik wieder wettzumachen
der russische präsident ist wieder
inhalten schlagzeilen er sitzt mit dem
amerikanischen kollegen an einem tisch
mit den europäischen kollegen demnächst
auch mit dem chinesischen
generalsekretär der lange mit dem nicht
sprechen wollte
damit kann russland wieder eine große
figur marken auf dem internationalen
parkett das alles aber funktioniert nur
solange kein echter krieg gibt
deswegen glaube ich auch dass es diesen
krieg in wahrheit nicht geben wird das
ist auch jetzt zu spät im grunde
genommen eine militärische operation
anzufangen meter januar das ist also ich
glaube für die nächsten
sechs monate haben wir ruhe
dann bis hierhin erstmal danke für ihre
einschätzung heute abend dankeschön
vladimir kaminer und
wir müssen vielleicht um diesen ganzen
konflikt den es auch nicht erst seit
gestern gibt schon an sondern wirklich
schon mehrere jahre um den wirklich
verstehen zu können müssen wir auch ein
bischen zurückschauen und thomas
consumer hat da eine chronologie
vorbereitet die wir uns jetzt mal in
einem beitrag anschauen können was ist
da genau passiert
anfang 2014 seit wochen gibt es proteste
auf dem majdan in kiew gegen die
abwendung der ukraine vom westen zuvor
hatte präsident janukowitsch ein
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu auf eis
gelegt und sie stattdessen russland
zugewandt dann der zwanzigste februar
2014 sicherheitskräfte eröffneten auf
dem maindamm das feuer mehr als 100 pro
europäische regierungsgegner sterben
janukowitsch flieht aus kiew das
parlament enthebt ihn des amtes kündigt
neue präsidentschaftswahlen an kurz
danach russland startet an der
ukrainischen grenze eine militärübung
mit
150.000 soldaten pro russische milizen
besetzen das parlament auf der halbinsel
krim
bewaffnete soldaten ohne hoheitszeichen
übernehmen die kontrolle über krim
flughäfen auf der halbinsel landen nach
ukrainischen angaben 2000 russische
soldaten
moskau nimmt die kripo fitzi l in die
russische föderation auf folge eu und
usa verhängen sanktionen gegen russland
in der ost ukraine besetzen
pro-russische separatisten
verwaltungsgebäude sie rufen so genannte
unabhängige volksrepublik 'nen aus start
eines bewaffneten konflikts mit bis
heute mehr als 13.000 toten
der proeuropäische petro poroschenko
gegen die ukrainische
präsidentschaftswahl er unterzeichnet
das auf eis gelegte
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu
die folge russland droht mit ernsten
konsequenzen
minsk friedensverhandlungen der westen
und russland nehmen teil eine waffenruhe
wird beschlossen eingehalten wird sie
nicht
an der krimm rand russlands küstenwache
ein ukrainisches marineschiff beschießt
weitere es ist die erste offene
militärische konfrontation zwischen der
ukraine und russland
russland zieht an der grenze zur ukraine
truppen und zehntausende soldaten
zusammen und zieht sie nach protesten
des westens und kiews wieder ab
dezember russlands präsident putin
fordert schriftliche zusagen der westen
solle auf einen nato osterweiterung
verzichten ebenso auf us
militärstützpunkte in der ehemals
sowjetischen einflusssphäre us-präsident
beiden droht beating greife russland die
ukraine an gebe es wirtschaftssanktionen
putin verlangt die ukraine dürfe kein
nato mitglied werden
januar zahlreiche diplomatische
bemühungen bleiben ohne greifbare
ergebnisse
moskau macht weiter mobil hat mehr als
100.000 soldaten an der ukrainischen
grenze sagen die usa und werfen moskau
vor einen vorwand für einen einmarsch
vorzubereiten russland dementiert
heute nun außenministerin bernburg
trifft ihren russischen amtskollegen
lawrow sie setzt auf dialog warnt aber
deutschland werde die europäische
friedensordnung verteidigen
wir können das ganze jetzt nochmal
einordnen und noch besser verstehen
gemeinsam mit sarah packung sie forscht
für die deutsche gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik ist expertin für
russische außen und sicherheitspolitik
schönen guten abend verpackung
ganz eben gerade in dem beitrag gesehen
also es gab da schon eine lange
geschichte mehrere eskalationsstufen
aber warum frau tagung hat sich das
jetzt erneut und jetzt gerade nochmal so
verschärft im moment
also zum einen ist es so dass russland
ja versucht hat über die vergangenen
jahre mit diplomatischen und politischen
mitteln einer weste integration der
ukraine zu verhindern und das problem
ist eben dass das so nicht geklappt hat
und jetzt eben die möglichkeit oder das
risiko besteht dass man das auch mit
militärischen mitteln versuchen das
zweite ist sicherlich auch dass russland
auch dazu jetzt in der lage ist weil es
eben politisch weil das regime
innenpolitisch seiner macht
konsolidieren konnte nach den letzten
parlamentswahlen auch nach der
niederschlagung der repression und
wir verstehen uns ja hier jetzt in der
sendung die frage also wie gefährlich
kann dieser ukraine konflikt noch werden
ich habe auch im stream schon gesehen
vanessa hauff fragt per mail droht ein
dritter weltkrieg also da gibt es jetzt
auch bedenken und ängste oder sie fragt
sich auch einen krieg auf ganz
europäischem boden frau packungen wie
ist da jetzt ihre einschätzung also wie
nah ist man da jetzt gerade wirklich an
so einer massiven eskalation dran
also das wissen wir vielleicht in zwei
teile auf tragen also zum einen haben
wir die gefahr eines krieges zwischen
der ukraine und russland und die würde
ich aktuell als hoch einstufen was nicht
heißt es zwingend passieren wird aber es
ist wirklich eine realistische und ruhe
gefahr und das wo von den zuschauern
zuschauer und sprechen das sicherlich
eher ein gesamteuropäischer kriegt das
würde ich nicht also das sehe ich nicht
kommen ganz einfach weil der schutz oder
die schutzfunktion der nato auch mit dem
artikel 5 weil so der bund nicht nach
wie vor noch sehr stark ist also einen
krieg zwischen russland und der nato
sehe ich nicht auch weil die natur ja
schon deutlich gemacht hat dass sie
selbst im falle einer russischen
invasion in der ukraine militärisch
nicht selbst eingreifen wird sie sagten
aber sie sehen eine hohe gefahr eben
zwischen ukraine und russland dass es da
eskalieren könnte jetzt sagt russland
selbst die würden kein einmal planen
dass sein also alles nur übungen da an
der grenze ist es dann nur ein bloß wie
ist es einzuschätzen
ja also diesen kommentaren würde ich in
der tat keine glaubwürdigkeit zu messen
zum einen weil wir das was wir auf dem
boden sehen also und die art wie weise
die qualität und quantität des
russischen truppen auf basis in jedem
fall für eine invasion geeignet ist und
zum anderen müssen natürlich auch sagen
das gleiche hat russland 2013 2014 von
der kollektion und den beginn des
krieges im don was ja ebenfalls gesagt
und auch da hat es ja nicht der wahrheit
entsprochen weil sie die glaubwürdigkeit
dieser aussagen gesetzlich sehr begrenzt
da passt eine frage die ich gerade
gesehen habe bei youtube gut dazu ich
glaube nutzer nutzerin heißt tmn und
zwar ist da auch wieder die frage kann
es sein dass putin pokert bis auf
wirtschaftliche sanktionen kann europa
doch nicht machen ist das so
der adressat dieses ja dieses russischen
pokerspiels bei man das so nennen will
ist natürlich aber auch nicht nur europa
sondern nicht nur die eu sondern vor
allen dingen auch die usa und wenn wir
europa und die usa zusammen nehmen dann
gibt es durchaus eine ganze reihe von
instrumenten und mitteln die man
einsetzen kann und das ist neben den
kooperationsangeboten die wir jetzt ja
sehen und auch den verhandlungen sind es
natürlich abschreckende maßnahmen
sanktionen also wirtschaftliche
sanktionen beispielsweise
exportbeschränkungen finanzielle
sanktionen wie der ausschluss aus dem
lift also im internationalen
zahlungsverkehr und das hätte wirklich
erhebliche konsequenzen auf sanktionen
gegen russische banken und letztlich ist
es eben auch so dass russland diese
eskalation ja nur provoziert um
bestimmte konzeption von europa und vor
allem zu bekommen also das heißt man hat
natürlich durchaus einfluss kanäle und
einfluss instrumente lassen sie uns
gerne in konkrete auf diese ziele und
interessen von russland eingehen also
was wollen die damit jetzt bezwecken
worum geht es also
ganz grundsätzlich geht es darum eine
beste integration der ukraine zu
verhindern und zwar nicht nur politisch
wie wirtschaftlich sondern vor allen
dingen auch ätherisch was wir seit
2013 2014 sehen ist dass die ukraine
sehr stark wie silvester integration in
die eu aber auch in die nato verfolgt
und das ist aus russischer sicht ein
sicherheits oder im militär schuss
risiko weil man eigentlich in die nato
möglichst weit von der eigenen grenzen
der karten möglichst weit
die eigene verteidigungslinie weg
schieben möchte und da ist natürlich
dann eine militärische kooperation
zwischen nato und der ukraine ein
potenzielles risiko und genau das möchte
man sprechen lassen es gibt ja
eigentlich auf einen plan der
geschlossen wurde der also so ein
bisschen den frieden zwischen den beiden
herstellern sollte das minsker abkommen
jetzt werfen sich beide länder ukraine
und russland gegenseitig vor sich nicht
an das abkommen zu halten könnten sie
das so ein bisschen einfach für uns
aufschlüsseln stimmt dass wer hat da
recht halten sich beide nicht dran
das ich lasse das mal zu erkennen also
das problem ist oder
minsker abkommen bei grundsätzlich dazu
gedacht eine art der konfliktlösung für
den konflikt im donbass also die dort
von separatisten besetzten gebiete zu
finden und da hat man einen gemeinsamen
fahrplan zu schaffen und der unterhält
wurde enthält unter anderem freie wahl
dort was und dann darauf aufbauend eine
verhandlung mit knapp über die über den
status wie viel autonomie wird es geht
oder die für nicht und es erhält als
weiteren punkt auch dass die ukraine
wieder die kontrolle über die grenze und
in diesem bereich weil dies ja aktuell
unter russischer
unter russischer kontrolle und die man
könnte sippel formieren die frage ist
einfach was macht man zuerst weil die
ukraine natürlich erst die grenze
sichern möchte um russischen einfluss zu
verhindern und russland das natürlich
ausreichend licht möchte weil es
russischen einfluss sichern möchte das
heißt die frage ist vielleicht nicht wer
hält es ein und erhält es nicht ein
sondern wie interpretiert man die
reihenfolge und auch das ziel von minsk
also ist es ein instrument zur
herstellung technischer souveränität
oder ist ein instrument zur beschneidung
und technische realität was würden sie
sagen
also ich denke dass das in jedem fall
ein informant zur herstellung
ukrainischer souveränität sein soll das
problem ist aber natürlich dass man ja
einen gewissen eine große einigkeit
herstellen muss weil russland ist
natürlich nicht offiziell konfliktpartei
in russland im sinne in der ukraine
sondern dass es das zugibt aber es hat
natürlich maßgeblichen einfluss auf die
separatisten im don was und das heißt
dann wird hier in irgendeiner form zu
einem gemeinsamen kompromiss kommen
müssen ich denke allerdings dass das
eher ein fernziel ist also kurz bis
mittelfristig glaube ich geht es einfach
nur darum eine größere eskalation zu
vermeiden
und dabei möchte jetzt auch deutschland
mit moderieren annalena baerbock die
außenministerin hat im vorfeld auch
gesagt sie will vor allem zu hören also
da will man jetzt vor allem
gesprächsangebote machen würden sie
sagen dass die aber auch in den letzten
jahren ausreichend vorhanden dann gab es
also genug gesprächsangebote für
russland oder gab sie vielleicht nicht
ja ich würde schon denken also wenn wir
uns alleine anschauen was es alles für
potenzielle formate gibt also neben den
bilateralen gespräch kann hat gibt es
den nato-russland-rat es gibt die osze
die sich wöchentlich trifft auf
botschafter innen ebene wir haben den
strategischen dialog innerhalb der osze
wir haben den nato wir haben den
un-sicherheitsrat die haben den
europarat und sie könnten das noch
weiter fortführen also kanäle haben wir
eigentlich genug das problem ist eher
der inhalt also wenn man also das ist
ein bisschen was nützt das ganze
sprechen wenn man sich nicht einmal auf
grundsätzliche gemeinsame prinzipien
einigen kann
ich möchte hier trotz allem auch noch
mal ein kommentar von youtube von
schlitzohr wie er sich nennt aufgreifen
er findet oder schreibt hört auf mit
dieser kriegstreiberei gegen russland
warum wird das von kritischen stimmen
manchmal so empfunden also dass man
quasi alle gegen russland das alle
sichtlich in russland verschworen hätten
wieso empfinden dass auch menschen in
deutschland in anderen ländern europas
so manche
also ich würde
es gibt eine vielzahl von gründen ich
würde den garpunkt drei dabei heraus
heben das ist zum einen dass viele
deutsche eine historische verantwortung
gegenüber russland aufgrund der
deutschen verbrechen im zweiten
weltkrieg
verspüren ich glaube dass das ein
schwieriges argument ist weil man dieses
diese verantwortung natürlich gegenüber
allen postulierte starten hat auch der
ukraine das zweite ist sicherlich dass
die ja also dieses
prorussische sortiment ein wenig in
der strategischen kultur deutschlands
verankert ist weil man sehr skeptisch
ist nicht nur gegenüber den usa und dem
ja und so genannte den besten und darf
so ein bisschen überträgt in brust des
gegen der es gegen den westen also sind
wir für russland und das andere und das
ist sicherlich ein wachsendes problem in
diesem jahr
dass wir es mit massiven russischen
informationskampagnen auch propaganda
kann spanien zu tun haben die sich vor
allen dingen in sogenannten alternativen
medien verbreiten und ich glaube das ist
ja eine mischung aus diesen drei und je
nachdem mit dem sie gleich sprechen
spielen da ganz persönliche und ganz
eigene kombination dieser aspekt
gegenteil wir haben jetzt auch schon
mehrfach in der sendung auch
angesprochen auch die usa stehen eine
rolle also nicht nur europa und am
freitag ist eben auch ein treffen
geplant zwischen dem us außenminister
und lavrov dem russischen außenminister
wie sehen sie die rolle der usa in
diesem konflikt
die usa haben sich alex zentrale rolle
in diesem konflikt weil sie letzten
endes adressat
der russischen vorstellungen oder im
erde der russischen ziele sind also
im sinne vor allen dingen von
truppenstationierungen auch der
stationierung von waffensystemen vor
allen dingen von von kurz und
mittelstreckenraketen das ist ja was was
vor allen dingen die usa machen können
auch weil die europäer europäer nach wie
vor in ihrer eigenen verteidigung
bericht nicht wirklich
fähig sind überhaupt agieren kann und
deswegen glaube ich kommt hier der usa
wirklich die zentrale rolle zu
ich schaue mir auch gerade nochmal in
die kommentare da gibt es schon einige
die sich aber fragen also was ist wenn
es jetzt nicht gut läuft mit der
kommunikation was ist also wenn doch ist
also zu einem angriff kommt auch das
wollen wir natürlich gerne hier jetzt
nochmal adressieren es gibt da mehrere
fragen zu also welche konkreten pläne
würden denn existieren wenn also ein
angeblicher angriff stattfindet möchte
jemand bei youtube wissen
genau also zum einen dass es so dass die
nato selbst ein militärisches eingreifen
ausgeschlossen hat ist das was sie aus
den zu anfang als wir müssen eigentlich
nicht befürchten dass die nato dort und
eigentlich mit reingezogen das andere
ist man natürlich dass man dann sehr
wahrscheinlich mit starken sanktionen
rechnen ich möchte da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
eine sprache schon an einem bahnhof
liegen bestimmte technologien
beispielsweise
möglicherweise auch energiebereiche
wurde ich dass er für unwahrscheinlich
halter aufgrund der europäischen
abhängigkeit hier dann natürlich auch
der ausschuss aus zwölf der aus dem
zahlungsverkehr gegen banken und das
hätte natürlich auch rückwirkungen auf
europa und auch deutschland vor allen
dingen im sinne der wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen im sinne des handels also da
müssten eben auch damit rechnen dass wir
das selber spüren wir müssen allerdings
auch noch mal sagen dass man so ein
bisschen in der relation zu setzen also
natürlich ist russland wirtschaftlich
aufgrund der rohstoffe sehr wichtig aber
der russiche oder der handel deutschland
mit russland hat ungefähr die gleiche
große wieder handel dort sonst wird
tschechien also es ist eben nicht so
dass russland die zentrale
wirtschaftliche bedeutung zukommt und
wir müssen das ist vielleicht der letzte
aspekt eben schon noch damit rechnen
dass bei einer anhaltenden und auch sich
verstärkenden sanktionspolitik die kluft
zu russland erst mal größer wird auch
weil wir damit rechnen müssen dass das
russische regime kurz bis mittelfristig
natürlich fest im sattel sitzt
wir haben jetzt auch schon mal gehört
also in diesem sanktions bereich könnte
eben auch nord stream zwei diese
pipeline die umstrittene die also gas
transportieren soll von russland nach
deutschland könnte also da vielleicht
auch betroffen seien wir realistisch
glauben sie aber dass das also
vielleicht auch genutzt werden könnte
von deutscher seite es gab ja jetzt
unterschiedliche meinungen dazu auch
innerhalb der ampel koalition
grundsätzlich ist es so dass es ja eine
vereinbarung zwischen den usa und
deutschland aus dem vergangenen sommer
gibt in deutschland zugesagt hat im
falle einer russischen aggression
gegenüber der ukraine
starke sanktionen zu ergreifen auch im
energiebereich sprich sollte es diese
einem intervention geben wird das sehr
schwer für deutschland und auch einigen
für die spd egal wie häufig versucht um
ein stopp von aus 42 herum zu kommen
auch weil wir letztlich damit rechnen
müssen dass werden die deutsche
bundesregierung ist nicht tot die usa
massiv funktionieren werden wir haben
ein us kongress der sehr stark gegen
dieses projekt ist und der eigentlich in
den letzten anderthalb jahren in seinen
sanktions versuchen nur
vom präsidenten beiden und seine
administration gebremst wurde um gute
beziehungen mit deutschland zu
ermöglichen und die frage ist ob das
noch so funktioniert im falle in der
intervention und das heck
lassen sie uns zum schluss dieser
sendung auch noch mal nach vorne schauen
wie könnte es weitergehen
da passt die frage von knusperhaus bei
youtube gut dazu denn es geht jetzt
darum erstmal soll einfach gesprochen
werden wieder zurück an den
verhandlungstisch und da fragt sich der
die userin sind die anstrengungen
seitens paybox wirkungsvoll russland
nimmt die eu nicht ernst und olaf scholz
hält sich auffällig zurück spd und
russland haben ja dank schröder einen
faden beigeschmack findet dieser user
diese userin
also um da wirklich eine bilanz zu
ziehen es ist wirklich noch viel zu früh
ich würde es zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
allerdings so bewerten dass die
tatsache dass berbalk bei ihrem
antrittsbesuch in der lage war einen
ersten beginnen oder zumindest
vorgespräche für verhandlungen innerhalb
des no money formates zu erreichen schon
mal als gutes zeichen sehen dann also es
wurde auch schon angesprochen wir haben
es in den letzten jahren durchaus häufig
gesehen dass die tomaten oder diplomaten
nach moskau gereist sind und relativ
aufgelaufen sind also letztes jahr erst
der eu aus bildrate borel der sich
dadurch erheblich getroffen und von da
aus wäre ich jetzt erstmal vorsichtig
optimistisch ob das dann am ende reicht
weil russland ja diese umfassenden
garantien forderte die der westen
letztlich nicht bereit ist zu geben das
ist was man hat als andere frage
was ist wenn die gespräche scheitern die
frage noch zum schluss
dann steigt das risiko eines krieges in
der ukraine noch mal deutlich und ich
glaube dann wird es schwierig das zu
verhindern
wir beobachten das ganze weiter für den
moment für heute abend erst mal vielen
dank an sarah packung das sieht das
ganze für uns jetzt hier eingeordnet
haben danke schön und
auf vielen dank an euch für die
aufmerksamkeit die vielen fragen und
kommentare ich hoffe ich konnte einige
von mitnehmen und beantworten und ich
bin mir sicher dieses thema wird auch
uns noch weiter beschäftigen und wir
bleiben dran für euch bis dahin tschüss